[Music]
actually the high roller is already lit
up red i got an
email on that so that's for that as well
good to see that mid 60s for a high for
the day 65 degrees
a mild and comfortable i mean this is
comfortable for december right feels
good
this is where we should be 59 degrees 41
the morning start now the mornings are
going to be chilly the afternoons have
been mild lately
and this time of year with that low sun
angle that's why the morning start
has been on the chilly side centennial
hill 61 right now summerlin 55
61 for aliante and the lakes at 64.
we're at 66
sunrise mountain 65 for green valley
roads ranch 59 degrees and 58 currently
for seven hills right now outside of
town 64 for prep 61 boulder city
and 66 for those of you joining us down
river in loughlin where you did have
that wind advisory that has now been
allowed to expire doppler network again
clear skies
looking dry right now the jet stream way
to the north but you'll notice
we're just on the other side of this dip
in here in the jet stream we're allowing
several
several disturbances to come down here
and increase our winds for us but as far
as precip goes showers that's not going
to happen all that's over here
in the midwest and also the rockies
where it's changing over to snow
cool air within the plains states all
the way down to the lone star state
we will see those winds pick up again on
wednesday originally we thought that
thursday would be the day we'd get the
strongest winds but the forecast always
changes right so
now looks like wednesday will be the
breezy day we'll see those winds pick up
a little by late morning been breezy by
midday and beyond
no wind advisory will be needed for the
las vegas valley and surrounding areas
we'll see those winds decrease
later on in the evening for tomorrow we
could see a lake wind advisory issued
again
but that's up the national weather
service and if that happens we will let
you know
on online and on social media and of
course on tv
41 degrees for the low chilly and clear
light breezes overnight 58 for tomorrow
breezy and cooler for tomorrow
with those gusts like we pinpointed out
could get up to 30 miles per hour
no wind advisory needed your extended
forecast now
here you go looking good temperatures
are going to be in the high 50s for
tomorrow
we're going to see those numbers drop
for tomorrow and beyond look at these
highs in the high 50s mid 50s for
thursday
overnight lows though are going to be on
the cold side look at that
mid 30s you had wind on that it's going
to feel more like the high 30s so below
freezing it's going to feel like with
those winds on wednesday night
to thursday and then milder as we get
into the weekend and into next week
not bad at all that's your most accurate
forecast brian over here